this is a production of cornell
university
hope everyone is uh doing great today
it's really an honor for me to be here
today to
present some
past research and also um some more
current work with uh diversity equity
inclusion initiatives that i've been
undertaking
so
and also want to preface that i've not
given an in-person talk since 2019 so
if i'm rusty please uh forgive me
so is dr buckler uh introduced already
my name is dr martin honey um
i had i'm very active on twitter so if
you have twitter feel free to follow me
at uh the morgan trail
it is a
ton on the oregon trail so it's kind of
cheesy but
hopefully you can remember it
so
i have a bit of an unusual
pathway into science
so
my undergraduate work was actually in
english literature
with an emphasis on science fiction oh
thank you
with an emphasis on science fiction so
i uh spent a semester abroad at
lancaster university in england
um there was doing like mainly like
shakespeare and like poets out there
and then i came back and then um
i was very interested in adaptation of
sci-fi from literature into film
and sorry capstone was on
the uh book with the understanding of
electric sheep by philip k dick
and the movie uh blade runner with the
harrison ford
and
the title was when loosely based on
becomes new defined the limits of
adaptation and the film blade runner and
flipkadix novel data instrument electric
sheep
and
i was interested in exploring like how
far can you take an adaptation
before it becomes like its own original
uh piece of work so that was kind of an
interesting uh project to focus on
so some of the experiences i've had over
the past decade
so as dr buckler mentioned i was out in
south korea
exploring plant resistance gene function
and
trying to produce more resistant crop
plants
in new york city
uh right before the pandemic i was with
the
startup company annika biosciences where
we were using living organisms to design
sustainable ways to track and trace uh
products through supply chains
which is um
you know big issue even now with the
supply chain issues currently we're
experiencing
and more recently uh teaching online
courses
for non-scientists
and working with the consulting agency
on um issues of ecological importance
so
the question that kind of brought me
from
sci-fi science fiction into science
reality was
you know plants have immune systems you
know it's something that i wasn't really
thinking about when i was a student
a lot of the
focus was on
human immune systems and human health
but i think that
for a lot of
students
myself
from my personal experience
um kind of plant immune systems were
kind of not
in the forefront of
the mind i would say
so uh
i was uh participating in the federal
work study program to help pay tuition
and
another thing that surprised me was that
i didn't even know you could work in a
science lab as part of that i thought
that you know work study it's like okay
i'll
networking cafeteria or the library or
something i didn't even know that like a
lab
stint was like covered by that program
so
the
lab that i was really interested in was
dr walter gasman's lab so he was doing
he's doing really interesting research
with client immune systems and plant um
health and everything so that was like
very
fascinating for me
so
this is a picture i took at the missouri
botanical garden this is the japanese
garden out there
and
if you
see here most of the plants are very
green and they're happy and healthy
and that's because most plants are
resistant to most pathogens
so
which is contrasted with this picture of
a bean field
so if you look on the
left hand side you see a row of nice and
healthy green
bean crops
and then right next to that
is a very sick um diseased
row there
and
this illustrates
that
with our
modern uh kind of
cropping systems we have a lot of the
same
genetic background that are planted out
there um if you have a pathogen that can
break through the resistance then you
can
it can be really devastating to you know
the field so
the
plants on the left have a gene that
makes them resistant against this
pathogen and then the plants on the
right are susceptible to that pathogen
so i did a lot of my
undergrad work
um
graduate level or sorry with a
model system arabidopsis italiana so
it's
kind of like the loudness of the plant
world
um
you know a very
early plant to be uh sequenced
grows very fast um
uh
surprisingly
you know resilient uh
hard to kill unless you forget to water
it
or something um and uh
very easy to infect with this model the
bacterial pathogen a cinnamon is serengi
a dc3000
which
at pepfar's tomatoes so if you look on
the right that's the tomato fruit with
it's uh
been infected so you can see the leaf
you have
like these uh
uh chlorotic yellowing areas and you
have the water soaked lesions there and
then you also have those similar
um water soaking on the fruit of the
tomato
so if you go to the store for example
and you're um
you know trying to buy a tomato
although this
this is a plant pathogen so you won't
get sick from it like
you know it's not
visually appealing to eat so you might
pass over that you know that fruit for a
healthy one
so this pathogen
enters leaves through the
stomata
um also through other openings for
example if like a caterpillar is chewing
on the leaf or
through the hydathodes like
on the outside of the leaf also
and this is a cross section showing the
apoplastic spaces where this colonizes
um
and the very far right is
a nice image um you know actually
showing bacteria in this epiplastic area
and
the apoplast is a pretty nutrient poor
um environment
uh so this is a so the bacteria
or
have ways to access nutrients from
the ins from the cells that are
surrounding them
so i like to think of the plant immune
system as kind of like a castle
so if you look at a this image of a
castle they're
built for um
fortified with defense defenses so you
have like you know thick walls you have
maybe a moat on the outside
uh you have um
maybe like archers that are can like
shoot down arrows from higher up
and uh plant immune system is also very
uh multi-layered
uh defenses
so i was talking about bacteria just as
an example but
um
there are also other pathogens you know
fungi and omi seeds
um
nematodes
viruses
some plants are also pathogens of other
plants so there's like a bunch of other
um
uh examples but kind of using bacteria
is kind of a oops just for just for this
example
and
uh
so the bacteria here
uh the bacteria that i was working with
has this
needle-like structure the type three
secretion system that it can secrete
these effector proteins into this cell
which can
uh
evolutionarily um
you know evolve to benefit the pathogen
in some way
and then on the other end of it
plants have these resistance proteins um
envious lr proteins that can detect
effectors and then
spark an immune response called eti
which is effector triggered immunity
and
if you see here there these receptors
are on the outside that can detect these
uh they're called pamps here
pathogen-associated molecular patterns
but
i believe that in the literature people
are moving more towards
mamps and microsoft nuclear patterns
which encompasses uh beneficial
pathogens or beneficial microbes as well
as harmful pathogens
and
so this just
shows kind of recognition of these
effectors by the r proteins
so some cases it's a direct recognition
so you have like the
effector that's directly interacting
with the resistance protein
but often you also have this indirect
recognition so
you have another host protein that's
existing in a complex with the
resistance protein and then
when the pathogen targets that post
protein then it can
um like set off the alarm for the
resistance protein
and this often results in uh
hypersensitive cell death so you get the
this is gonna wrap it up to sleep leafs
on the left is the
um
uh
normal looking leaf and then when you
have this recognition you can oftentimes
get this
you know crinkled uh
program cell death response
and so these are some examples of some
of the general structures of the
resistance proteins so
kind of the conserve features or this
mds lrr
motif in the middle
and then at the end terminus
you know the
variable domain so maybe a total
interlinking receptor domain or a coiled
coil domain
and then at the c terminus you can have
other
um additions as well so one example is
the
uh wrky
uh so
orchies are plant specific transcription
factors
but
plants have evolved to
use this is kind of like a decoy to
detect the pathogen so that's a very
clever
trick
so why even study these effectors in the
first place
so
as i mentioned earlier no points are
constantly evolving pathogens are
evolving
um
there's
this term the uh arms race that's going
on between the plants and pathogens
and you know studying the vectors that
are out there
currently
um gives this one to under the state of
their evolutionary conflict
and may help us to predict where the
conflict is going potentially
and
you know ideally the goal is to be able
to
uh you know create resistant plants
and also effectors can help us identify
the
salient features of the immune system
so i kind of like to think of them as
you know a lot of the results of the
millions of years of co-evolution so
um you know each
effector is um
i
you know already been selected to be
doing something so
using them as kind of guides to what are
the important parts of the host plan
and currently we have
a lot of
rapid
sequencing techniques that we can use so
um you know rapidly sequencing
uh emerging pathogens and
getting those sequences out quickly
and
uh interestingly a prediction of
effector function based on the sequence
alone
isn't always that reliable
a lot of these effectors are
molecular mimics so they have
structures that resemble structure
uh structures of host proteins but the
sequences are
perfect for the sequences
so
using these just kind of like probes to
connect amino acid sequence with
structure
um i feel like i wrote i wrote this part
before um
i don't have a lot of
really fun uh
structure prediction
computational tools that are out there
now like deepmind and all these things
so um
you know i think it could still be
interesting but
um
yeah we'll see what how things go with
the the uh computational prediction
so the uh factor that i was studying is
this student was avr ps4
which is a pretty unusual effector
is i'll get to
later so i was working with um
walter over here my pi and then uh cyca
it was a stock and somehow stock
and
we found that average 4 interacts with
this immune regulator called eds1
so eds1
is a protein it's a positive regulator
of immunity so if you knock it out then
oftentimes you get hypersusceptible
plants
and i want to mention that having
mentors as allies is really important so
walter
is a was a very fantastic ally for me as
a black student in the lab
who um
i'll tell a story here that i told to uh
uh both dr buckler's uh last night
so
i know that some of you have already
probably uh submitted grfp
um proposals for nsf
so
um i submitted
you know nsf proposal to look at avira
ps4
and
they got the reviews back so
two of them were
outstanding you know very excellent
broader impacts
you know
cool idea um
you know this is fantastic
and then the third one was like totally
opposite of that which happens a lot of
time
um it was i got
they sent me like a bulleted like a
numbered list of all the things that
were wrong with it
um
like kind of like not mentioning the
strengths of it they were like all the
weaknesses so like
um number one you know having a
humanities background means that i want
to succeed in science
number two
um
uh
it's unclear how much of this was
written by your advisor which is like i
wrote it so that was kind of uh
insulting in a way to like
almost like accusing me of plagiarism or
something
third one was
as a minority student the applicant
should have done more to help other such
students
um
kids participate actively in a variety
of
outreach activities none specifically
targeting minority students
and at the very end they wrote
um
this application has merits but
these weaknesses temper my enthusiasm
period like that was like kind of like
hurtful as a student to hear those
comments and everything and so like i
printed it off and i
showed it to walter and then walter's
like oh this is like this is not good
like
no this should have been caught at the
program manager level like how i'd even
get back so then he called the program
manager and then
emailed nsf and then nsf email back and
then
basically um
you know these are blind reviews we
can't reveal who the reviewers are
and without without talking to them we
don't know what they were
what they meant by the by the um
comments about you should have done more
minority outreach instead of i was
focusing on
rural outreach so i'm from a very small
town
in western missouri near the kansas
border so like we were
very
not only economically
underserved but also
um you know the nearest university is
over an hour away um
uh the
you know the resources that are there
are just not that great
so that's and then also
um
part of a grant is to be
what can be what's feasible and not just
the idealistic
pie in the sky type of ideas so
um that's why i focused on that and then
you know two other viewers are like oh
that's excellent and then one of them is
like
no
you're black so you should have done
more to help other black students like
that was like weird to me
but
walter was like very
immediately like went to my defense and
then tried to
um
you know at least like point out this
attention so that
hopefully um
the reviewer can
someone can maybe talk to them if they
ever you know know who they are so
um i want to mention that you know being
an ally allies was very helpful to me
and i think it's like such an important
uh
uh thing to be
so i'm going to go back to science again
i'm kind of like interloping science
with personal background so bear with me
so
avrps4
once it goes into the plant cell it gets
split up into two different fragments so
you have this
n-terminal and c-terminal
fragment
and the c-terminal fragment
is
sorry the internal fragment is very
similar to the n-terminal fragment of
another effector called hopk1
but the c-terminal fragments are
very know very little sequence
similarity between those between those
two this is just an alignment of the
um
a reference four at the top with hopkins
at the bottom
and so building on the earlier finding
that
uh
seemed like the interminus was
interacting with eds one so
we're thinking like maybe the interminus
has a role in immunity or disease
susceptibility
so there's a paper um
from todayus uh roblovsky
from uc davis in um
richard mitchell moore's lab
so he did a
pretty high throughput screening of
different effectors against different
cultivars of lettuce
so
uc davis has a lot of
a
huge library of like different lettuce
cultivars
and
so the red is
the most um
severe hypersensitive response cell that
responds and then the green
the lighter the green like the uh
less response there is
so
it was interesting that the pattern of
aviator ps4 with hopk1
seemed like almost identical
and knowing that the
c terminal domains are so different then
i i was thinking like maybe the internal
domains
um
is what's causing that
phenotype
so then
i don't know
if anyone is from the midwest or who has
heard of a store called um hyvee
it's like a it's like a grocery store
so
we emailed davis to get some of these
cultivars to test but then
i was so excited i wanted to like test
it as soon as possible so i went to
hyvee and got some lettuce seeds from
ivy
and we um
this is elizabeth and connor rogan who
are undergrads who are helping me along
with this
um
elizabeth is
at university of minnesota now and um
she actually switched to
human uh human health so she's doing an
md phd program out there
um
she's gotten
she has more publications than i do
actually it's really amazing
uh she's um
doing a lot of uh covid um cover 19
research now so she's been very
productive
and then uh connor is at oregon state
university
um
uh working with
jeff anderson uh
on uh pathogens out there so
so this um
is infiltrating with agrobacterium to um
expressing different parts of europe
sport to see what the phenotype is
and
so
what was
not not very surprising but exciting was
that
aviary ps4
n-terminus over here and then hopkin one
in terminus here
like both gave that cell death response
which indicated that it's doing
something with um it's being recognized
in some capacity
and
the c terminus the pop k-1 or the
c-terminus of air ps4 didn't give us any
response at all
and
the full-length version
of
average ps4 and hopkin one
um
both gave kind of like an intermediate
level of
um response and then empty vector just
to show that it's not something else
causing it
and then
[Music]
uh we did um
eye on leakage assays so
uh which is a marker for cell death
so
the blue is it four in terminus has the
highest
amount of ion leakage
compared to
down here you have empty vector and then
in between or the other so
um
avrps4c maybe a little bit of something
um within margin of error
and then full-length and then um
we also did like a
condemnation so
intermission c-terminus at the same time
you know also gives kind of this level
of response
and then um
just a protein blot showing that they're
being expressed in everything and then
that their
uh equal level of um input there
so then we came up with this like bottle
for the evolution of chimeric effectors
so
on the y-axis is the amplitude of
defense and then on the
x-axis is the
got cut off there a little bit i think
um
but this is the let's just say
evolutionary time okay thank you
sorry no you're totally good no no
problem
so if your ps4 and terminus
so um i apologize for all the acronyms a
pti is uh again parent target immunity
um
average ps4 n suppresses that
two etsy effects triggered
susceptibility
then you have an r protein that comes in
which gives eti so you have more defense
and then
you get a fusion of
a new c terminus with the interminus
which again brings you down to
a susceptible level
and then
this new um
rps4 rs one is the
rgm care that recognizes avrps4 and you
get
eti again so kind of a
little bit like the zigzag model that of
plant immunity so
so
apologies for the analogy
so most plants are resistant to most
pathogens
but likewise we humans have the
but uh
likewise achievements of the ability to
resist racism in scientists in science
but it takes work
so i was one of the co-founders of black
botanist week which
started
last summer of 2020
right after the
um central fargo bird watching incident
um and the
um around the same time as the
um
murder of george floyd and brianna
taylor also
and
so tanisha over here
sorry
cover came off
she put out the call on twitter she's
like hey
um
there's this black birders week that was
started i think we should do something
similar with lot with black botanists
so then
11 of us
kind of
came together and
with a way to move this forward
so there's tanisha
there's knox who's a professor at a
stellenbosch university in
south africa
there's georgia who's also in new york
city
with um
washington square park eco projects
brandy cannon
was in new york city but she's
starting grad school at stanford pretty
soon here
jade is a grad student
at
in the uk
and natasha
is a student who's really interested in
so natasha it's amazing she did all of
our logos and artwork and everything and
she's a
amazing artist and also
combines um
photography and art with science
rupert is
a directorate
botanical society in south africa
maya is a grad student in new mexico
um there's me who
i feel honored to be i don't feel
deserving to be in the presence of
everyone everyone else here
and then there's a bronda who
is an amazing professor at michigan
state university who recently wrote a
book that i'll get to later um if you
haven't checked it out yet called
lessons from plants
and then
tatiana is a grad student
in
california
and then tim along is
um recently graduated grad school and he
is in
kind of going back and forth between uh
canada and south africa so
so
one and i think it was like amazing also
is that
just the scale of
you know across continents across age
groups
across um
career
stages
but
we all got together to
get this moving forward
and it's an ongoing movement so
we've recently had the
2021 black bottom this week which was
also very successful
and uh this is me with uh
georgia and brandy before she moved to
california
um
we had like a little meet up we did like
a
a wildflower walk and like it was just
really cool like see each other in
person because like we'd only met
virtually at that point so
and
so we wanted to have each day be
different and then also differentiate it
from like last year's version also so
i'm trying to get a new um
new spin on it
and
i don't have how much time do i have
left uh
so i should have had my timer going
oh awesome oh thank you so much
so
um
the original black button this week we
had so much um
positive social media
help and support um margaret fray uh
that's what i thought okay great to meet
you in person
um i want to say thank you because you
did an amazing job like amplifying us
and like spreading the word and
everything so thank you so much for that
and
we had um
[Music]
even margaret atwood the author
made a tweet about us she's like oh
everyone should check out this black
bottom this week
um
we had a usa today feature we had
georgia went on the
new york city's biggest uh radio
new york city is an npr affiliate to
talk about it so we had like a really
nice um
exposure and it was just like a very
uplifting thing
and another thing i'd like to point out
so we gave a lecture series
um
in collaboration with um holden forest
and gardens
called uh growing black roots the black
botanical legacy
and so all of us
gave a gave our own different talk
and like each of it each of them were
very um
different and unique and we had a lot a
lot of freedom to
explore kind of whatever we wanted to um
if as long as it related to
um you know black experience with plants
and so
i think my talk is on youtube
so i delved into a lot of um
you know personal background of
um you know growing up in a
you know a small
95 white town and then kind of that
experience
and um
so just very briefly so
i go into more detail in that talk but
my um
great great great great grandfather
yes i want to make sure i get called
all the greats correct um
was the
slave of the founder of my hometown
and
so i'm like the first generation to
actually leave my hometown so like my
mom is still living there dad's still
living there um
we have that like you know direct line
to um
being brought there from kentucky with
um
general george r smith is his name
very uh
there's there's a long history back
there so if you want to check out the
talk at your own leisure
um and then also
all the other talks are just
so and i got so much from them and
they're so interesting and
they each cover a dif very different
um
you know different corners so to speak
so they're really amazing
so we recently published um this paper
so well not recently it was like earlier
this year uh growing a community the
inaugural blackbox week recap looking
forward
and
this is just a way to
kind of
see how things went for the first year
and then
um
offer kind of like a window window
towards the future for how we wanted to
see how things
progress and everything
and
we have five action night five action
items in this in that publication that i
can go through quickly
so the first one
is a journey of truth and unlearning the
propaganda you have been taught to keep
the system of oppression in place
we're asking everyone to dig deep and
learn about the true history of your
country in the world examine how
continued compliance or negligence of
citizens and the passing of laws have
systematically disadvantaged black
people around the world
and the second
one listen to black people about their
lived experiences
examine why it's so hard to hear and
empathize with someone else's truth
the third one
identify racial inequalities and
disparities
so these should be identified in every
aspect of one's life healthcare
education income
examine how these inequalities and
disparities harm black people
the fourth one
identify racist and or biased ideas
implicit or not you your organization
etcetera hold
examine how these ideas came to be
what's wrong about these ideas and
working with effectively change racist
views and or biases
and the last one is
as for the people organizations and
legislation that are actively doing
anti-racist work
there are many local national and global
civic organizations working towards
racial equity and social justice
um no ways in your daily life you could
actively work towards being anti-racist
and counter counteracting persistent
biases and inequalities
um it's a lifelong commitment we almost
make to
see a world where there is equality for
all
and
i also wanted to
commend
cornell um i was going through um
uh lab
photos and everything i was looking at
at dr buckler's lab and just like saw
the racial diversity there which is not
it's not like that most of the time i
would say so um i was like very happy to
see that um
um
i was talking with um dawn earlier who
just had to take off but
we're talking about how
a lot of universities sometimes
they put out a statement like you know
we support
we support you and everything but don't
actually have any
actions behind the words so
um
you know it's like it's really cool to
see examples where
there is um
kind of like an idiom like putting money
where your mouth is so to speak and uh
actually backing up boards with action
so um
just get using uh don't want to pick one
software i just want to um commend
your lab for being such a diverse group
and everything so
and i mentioned earlier uh dr montgomery
has this book that i really recommend
reading uh called lessons from plants
and this came out from
very recently uh this year and
she does a great job of
interweaving her personal experiences of
being a professor of plant biology
with
the
through observing plants how
we humans can
learn
tolerance and acceptance and
um
adaptability
and
community enrichment and helping
those around you she has a very good
quote
that she i don't know if it's in the
book but she mentioned this in our talk
that i heard recently
it's that we should be
groundskeepers more than gatekeepers and
by that what what she's saying what she
said was um
a lot of
academic academia is um
you know kind of
gatekeeping so
which can lead to
if not conscious bias
uh unconscious bias
so
instead you know being a groundskeeper
so um
um
being more compassionate being
open to
admitting our our own um
faults and mistakes so i really this
book is really amazing i highly
recommend it
and i'll finish off with a personal
observation
so through all the spaces i've been
through not many people look like me
however they're hopeful signs of change
in academia and elsewhere
we can't expect others to change things
for us we should be actively part of the
change
and
i was talking with dr buckler
earlier
about how
it's hard to see change as you're going
through it sometimes but then you can
like look back
10 years 20 years down the road and be
like oh yeah
we were things were actually improving
at the time i just didn't really notice
it if that makes sense
so um
i think that
i'm already seeing a lot of hopeful
signs of change so um
i'm uh
definitely optimistic on this
on this front
um
i had a longer talk uh
i would go into climate change and
everything you know other things that
could be off hopefully i wish i could be
more optimistic about but um i think on
this front i think changes are happening
and
um i was talking with don earlier and he
mentioned
how um
it's
very um
trying to give the word the wording that
he used um
it's
oh my gosh i'm like blinking on
it it was it was to the effect of like
you know change um you know being hard
to notice in the moment but um
looking back you'll see how you know how
far we've come in everything so
um
and i will end there and
i wanted to thank you so much for coming
and
um this is my first in-person talk since
for like two years or something so this
is really i was like really honored to
be here and
um i hope i have time for questions if
anyone has any so thank you so much
yes
so how
you know it looked like i couldn't see
about five different activities but were
they all in new york city or
that people kind of
were doing different activities in
different locations for black fun this
week and how is that kind of working
that's a great question so
we were
worldwide um so
and this was you know during the
early days of the pandemics so we were
all doing it virtually for the most part
um
and
one thing that we were
you know we're this is still has a lot
of momentum to it so we're to keep this
going forward
i envision it as being
less of a
you know blackboard this week for
2020 2021 2022 and
make it instead more of like a um
not not to use a plant but like a
perennial as opposed to an annual
thing so
kind of have it you know
go uh
kind of throughout the year more so that
would be amazing that's a really good
question
yes
so um currently black bottom this week
is in july correct correct
have you all
considered
moving it to
a time period when schools are open to
sort of have the opportunity
um
for a
partnership and collaboration with
schools and teachers especially life
science teachers to introduce it to
children at a younger age because
in my mind
july's great because you have so much
bloom
the downside of it is unless you're a
child who has access to some type of
active school care or some type of
um
summer camp with things as
extracurricular type activities
you don't necessarily have the
opportunity to have guided
um engagement with something like this
that i think a lot of children uh
nationwide much less globally would be
very interested in
that is a great great point uh are you
sure right
oh my god i'm so sorry oh my gosh i
apologize i met some of that i was like
trying to
keep my name straight and everything i'm
so sorry oh yeah um so that is a great
question so
that's something that
we have in july mainly for like
just like historical significance now
since like the first one started during
um
uh
you know the black lives matter when
that was starting up and everything and
other
um
you know other groups are coming up like
you know black and neuro black and
microbiology all these things
so um
we are
thinking
me personally i don't want to speak for
the committee but uh i personally would
be
open to having more like during the
school year during the big year and um
you know increasing um
collaboration with you know students and
universities and that sort of thing
um i was talking with don earlier he
mentioned um
uh you know increasing collaboration
with uh
other botanic gardens things like that
so that's a really great point and
we're gonna be meeting we have another
meeting coming up soon so i will bring
that up so
aaliyah yes perfect i'm so sorry i don't
know if i had alicia in my head i'm so
sorry i apologize apologies
so many people today exactly
but i won't forget it now it's like as
soon as i get a name wrong then
i remember it more
you know primary intermediate stage
to get that proverbial ball rolling
that's that's where the
you're gonna grab those children's minds
and get them interested
that's fascinating you know absolutely
um
that was a great question so that's
another thing that i was thinking about
um
so one thing i've done i didn't talk
about it in this talk but um
i guess a little bit when i was
mentioning going to uh
um underserved communities and
everything so
you know going to
you know middle schools high schools
um
you know just
having them see
another black botanist
in front of them like is an actual
actually a real thing
um you know per again like i didn't even
know that
a plant research career was even a thing
until i heard about walters lab and
through the work study program and i'm
like well that's like amazing that i
didn't even
never even knew that existed you know so
i think um
definitely
a lot of our work has been towards
adults with bloodbotton this week but i
think
definitely doing more for um
at that age when
students don't even know the
uh options that are out there and
possibly possible
i'm so tongue-tied possibilities that
are out there so i think that would be
fantastic
yes so i guess to piggyback on all the
other comments is
did you have any suggestions about how
uh on the instructor level i'm an active
learning postdoc so i said in a lot of
the undergraduate classes
how can we incorporate you know black
that is a great question uh what's your
name
anna so
one thing um
we do have some resources and like
classroom ideas and activities
we've we have them deposited on the
holden forest and garden website where
they have the lecture series so
and
they're kind of um
tailored towards each topic and idea but
like a lot of them are
can be broadly applicable i would say so
if you go to that website and i can um
it's like just the whole enforcers
website and then
um
click on the black growing black roots
section
there's a bunch of resources on there
you can um use it for really on twitter
absolutely awesome
exactly
yes
i was just going to say as a plant
pathologist i very much appreciate it oh
thank you
awesome
thank you so much just following you
today
and i was also gonna say i completely
agree with you about brandon
montgomery's book and i'm just gonna
tell the audience that we do actually
have free copies of the book available
and the sixth main office if anyone is
interested
oh awesome so who was it what around the
thing
oh that's awesome yeah and then and then
the coolest part was we got into groups
and not just faculty and faculty faculty
and staff students with postdocs yeah it
was really really amazing to sit and
talk
oh that's good for people but we just
sat outside this is wonderful oh that's
so amazing i'm sorry to hear that and
i'll tell her when i meet with her next
and she'll be so excited
that's awesome
yes
so uh
i'll try to
figure out where they have some
questions here um so
downstairs on our
lcd screen we have
a couple of
graphics about sew and spent this is how
little i picked it up like um the names
of uh two
people from i think like the 1910s
right and then there's just sort of
90 years of
buckets basically
and um
we had an external
audit of sip i think it was all of sips
and it looked at um not just
the demographic breakdown of our faculty
and student body but also our applicant
pool i believe
and uh perhaps the most disappointing
was the
real lack of diversity in our applicant
pool
both at the student grad student and
faculty level
um and so this is classic you know white
person asking black people like what are
we doing wrong and how come
[Music]
but
what have you seen at other schools that
are
schools of plant science in general that
um
they're doing
to attract
plant scientists and students who are
interested in plant science who were not
white or southeast asians
that's a great great question and
another thing i should have pointed out
i talk about this more in my holden talk
but
it's not just
uh you know things that
you know at the university stage there
is a
you know long history of systemic racism
in our country so and that's what i was
talking about like my slavery ancestors
and the um
lack of opportunities that have been
going down and like i'm first generation
to leave my hometown
and everything so
um
that is the tap root of a lot of the
problems i would say so um
uh you know going back to slavery and
not having those equal opportunities and
everything
so
what
we
what we all collectively should be doing
um
is
this is getting kind of philosophical
but you know like working on legislation
and
um
trying to
narrow those disparity gaps so um
um like i'm a big fan of like slavery
reparations for example um like those
won't help narrow the gap but like won't
close the gap that might help narrow the
gap i would say
and
um
breaking down
the disparities that are neighborhood by
neighborhood and
you're
in a certain school which enables you to
get which limits your chances to go
somewhere else and
um
there's
so much like inbuilt
structure there for
social um
climbing to even get to the point of
the application stage anyway
so um
i think that a lot of that's out of our
hands but
i think that
doing the
starting off with our own like
self-reflection and like the action
items
um those are small changes which
will eventually down the road lead to
bigger like legislative change and
um
it's you know romo's rome wasn't built
in the days so it's gonna take many many
years but um
uh
i think each person kind of individually
doing what we can is going to be very
beneficial so that's a great question
and um
it's uh
and
i feel like this talk was kind of like
focusing on like ways that science can
improve but it's
not just science it's
other parts of society also so um
it's a
that's something i should have brought
up earlier but yeah it's a
can you know a big canopy that science
is a part of so
well
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu